to understand what symmetry is let's
draw an isosceles triangle
it's a triangle in which two of its
sides are equal now let me give you an
easy task you need to think if we can
divide this triangle into two parts such
that both the paths match exactly when
they're folded along the line how would
you divide the triangle if this
condition has to be satisfied fold it
along the line such that both parts
formed match exactly pause the video and
give it a shot
it's easy and I'm sure most of you would
have got it right if we draw a line like
this the condition will be satisfied yes
it's a vertical line which divides the
triangle into two parts which match
exactly when folded along the line if
the part on the right is taken over to
the left we see that they overlap
exactly and that is why this shape is
said to be symmetrical the two parts
match exactly when folded along a line
now let me give you another figure I
draw the isosceles triangle this way and
ask you the same question how would you
divide the triangle into two parts such
that both the paths match exactly when
they are folded along the line yes we
can draw a horizontal line like this we
get two paths which match exactly when
one is folded or flip it overlaps
exactly over the other both these lines
we see here are called the lines of
symmetry or the axis of symmetry this
triangle has a vertical axis of symmetry
as this line is vertical and this one
has the horizontal axis of symmetry as
this line is horizontal now I want you
to think about the next question I'm
going to ask you can a shape has more
than one axis of symmetry if you look at
just these two triangles
you must robably say no because there is
no other line which can divide these
triangles into two parts that match
exactly but the correct answer is the
other shape can have more than one axis
of symmetry
look at this whipped angle these two
parallel sides are equal these two
parallel sides are equal and all four
angles measure 90 degrees it will have a
horizontal axis of symmetry like this
when one part is flipped over it will
overlap exactly with the other and it
will also have a vertical symmetry like
this flip this part and BC the perfect
overlap so a rectangle has a horizontal
as well as a vertical line of symmetry
but wait
some of us may be wondering if the
diagonals are also the axis of symmetry
let's say we have a diagonal like this
you can see that folding it along the
diagonal does not give us matching parts
you can try this with a page from your
notebook try and fold it along the
diagonal and you will see that the parts
do not overlap exactly okay here's
another question for you can you figure
has more than two axis of symmetry if
yes then which figure again the answer
is yes take the example of a square all
the sides are equal and all four angles
are right angles it has the horizontal
as well as the vertical axis of symmetry
just like the rectangle but for a square
the two diagonals will also be the axis
of symmetry if we fold it along this
diagonal the paths match and even if we
fold it along this diagonal these two
paths overlap exactly so a square has
four axis of symmetry horizontal
vertical and the two diagonals more than
four what if we have a figure like a
regular hexagon a regular hexagon is a
closed figure with six equal sides and
six equal angles
how many axis of symmetry does a regular
hexagon have pause the video and try to
arrive at the correct answer
okay let's see the horizontal and the
vertical ones are obvious these two
diagonals would also be the axis of
symmetry do you think there are any more
yes the line joining the midpoints of
these two sides and the line joining the
midpoints of these two sides will also
be the axis of symmetry folding the
figure along any of the lines
forgive us matching past six in all and
a circle on the other hand has infinite
axis of symmetry no matter how we draw
the line passing through the center the
two paths formed will always fold
perfectly along that line did you know
that nature love symmetry the best
example of symmetry in nature would be
that of a human face it has a vertical
axis of symmetry what we saw in this
video is reflectional symmetry if one
part is kept against a mirror if the
reflection will give us C at the part
let's say we keep half the hexagon on
this side of the mirror its reflection
will give us the other half hence it's
called reflectional symmetry if there's
some other type of symmetry - yes we
will cover that in the next section
[Music]